نفايات طعام زيت الطهي ،
حتى ملابسك القديمة ، يمكن
استخدامها جميعًا للطيران بالطائرة ومكافحة تغير
المناخ.
المقترحات
الطموحة للطيران كجزء من صفقتها الخضراء
اعتبارًا من عام 2025 ، سيتعين على الطائرات التي تنطلق من
مطارات الاتحاد الأوروبي استخدام مزيج من
وقودين مستدامين على الأقل للطيران يرتفع
إلى 5 في عام 2030 و 63 بحلول عام 2050 ، المشكلة
الآن هي أن الموظفين فقط يمثلون 0.1
في المائة من
شركة الطاقة العملاقة في سوق وقود الطائرات تأمل في
تغيير خططها للبدء في إنتاج حوالي
2 مليون طن من النسغ سنويًا بحلول عام 2025.
إنها تتعاون مع
شركة تصنيع محركات الطائرات البريطانية رولز رويس ، وهم يدفعون
للحصول على طائرات لملء 100
يقصر المنظمون الآمنون في الوقت الحالي الطائرات على 50 مزيجًا
من وقود الطائرات التقليدي بحلول عام 2025 ،
ستنتج القشرة وحدها 10 أضعاف ما ينتجه
جميع المنتجين المختلفين  اليوم ،
هذا يكفي لا لن يكون كافيًا ،
هل صناع السياسات هم
المنظمون هم ما يجب أن يحدث
للحصول على المزيد من النسغ واستخدام المزيد من
شركات الطيران ، يتعلق الأمر في الغالب
بظروف السوق التي تعرفها ، لذا فإن
الوقود الأحفوري الآن رخيص
جدًا وبدون  أي تدخل من قبل
شركات الطيران الحكومية سيستمر بشكل صحيح تمامًا
في استخدام أرخص مصدر
للوقود وهو خزانات الوقود الأحفوري في
الوقت الحالي ليست رخيصة مثل
الوقود الأحفوري في الواقع في الوقت الحالي فهي
باهظة الثمن
للغاية ولذا يتعين علينا إجراء بعض
التدخل التنظيمي.  من أجل
تشجيع تكثيف قوى السوق الآمنة
، لن تكون كافية هنا
، لن تكون قوى السوق كافية
في ترسانة بلجيكا ، تتعاون
ميتال مع لانزاتيك لتحويل النفايات من
مصانع الصلب إلى إيثانول ،
فهي تبني تقنية عالية التقنية  باستخدام
تقنية مختلفة لديها القدرة
على زيادة إنتاج النسغ ، هذا
ما نفعله هنا في هذا المصنع هو
إعادة تدوير الكربون ، لذا كان للكربون
استخدام أساسي في  مطحنة الفولاذ
ومع هذه المنشأة هنا يمكننا
تخمير الكربون لاستخدام ثانوي ،
هذه العملية فريدة من نوعها ، فنحن نستخدم الغازات في
الكحول لذلك لا يزال تخميرًا
ولكنه محفز حيوي يفعل هذا ، فهو
ليس خميرة ، بل يمكن للبكتيريا والبكتيريا
تستهلك أول أكسيد الكربون
وغازات الهيدروجين
وتحويلها إلى إيثانول
لمدة ثلاث سنوات في تصنيع المصنع
مدعومًا ماليًا من السلطات الأوروبية والحكومية ،
ومن المقرر أن يبدأ تشغيله
اعتبارًا من عام 2022 ويتعهد بتقديم 64000
طن من الإيثانول سنويًا يمكن
استخدامه  بالنسبة للعديد من القطاعات من
العطور والمنظفات إلى وقود الطيران المستدام ،
اعتدنا أن نكون صناع للصلب نصنع
الفولاذ والآن ننتج الإيثانول
باستخدام تكنولوجيا التكنولوجيا وهناك
يمكنك أن تجد الكثير من أوجه التآزر ، فإن
إهدار صناعة واحدة هو مخزون كبير
من  على جميع القطاعات الأخرى النظر
في هذا الأمر وعليهم
التعاون لنفترض أن واحدًا وواحدًا هو ثلاثة
وليس واحدًا والآخر اثنان في هذه الحالة ،
يمكنك  في الكثير من أوجه التآزر هذه التي
تعزز انتقال الطاقة
الخضراء ومعالجة تلوث الطيران ، يعد
جهدًا جماعيًا لقادة الأعمال الأوروبيين
[موسيقى]